back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
Wow cat looks good today you look
nothing you always look nice you always
look nice also Derek comes in looking
different than cattle sexy but not as
yeah just a little bit a little Kenny
loften vibe yeah Kenny loften that's
Derek oh yes except to compare him to a
darker skinned person he could be a
white guy dude he could be I met his dad
this weekend did you really
wider oh yeah you guys just went back
east huh yes Wow his dad's really wide
huh his dad looks like exactly like him
but white a little drunk got a hole that
sammy sosa lotion with us yeah why don't
save me sister come out with a lotion
dude talk about marketing genius bro
come out with me with that lotion yeah
why doesn't he market lotion I don't
know that's a black to white man dude a
lotion a steroid brah dude that was the
best time when all the players are on
steroids oh you talk about the Golden
Age you know these guys are all afraid
to shoot up oh my god what a bunch of
windows 10 homeruns anymore and one
sitting base hit yeah up [ __ ]
we got bunted real hard the other day
might as well watch soft it's getting
interesting dude I went to Disneyland
man I saw unit is man with the fam
mm-hmm how was it man
happiest place on earth I mean it's
something bro it's not is it
that's something why as a father you can
through your all bats oh wow have you
taken your kid there yeah we have season
pass come on dude first of all what
spoiled kid gets a season pass to
Disneyland all right that guy's guy
can't get me do with drugs in six years
100% you know I'm aware of this oh that
gotta be Donald ducking up his arteries
with some [ __ ] smack with a couple of
[ __ ] Street grams bro I feel you dude
dude they have to there has to be a
correlation between children that have
season passes it is
and I'm doing smack by the age of twelve
back under a bridge whatever set but it
depends who's your kids favorite
character if they gravitate towards
Mickey's dumb ass then they're probably
in the cocaina you know I'm saying they
like Donald they like Donald different
animals Donald's geeked up on that quack
I feel like he's on that [ __ ] quack
cocaine what Donald can't pedal is that
from was that from the cruise or that's
the birdhouse or this is also
traditional Asian garb so I wore this
for cat and chimp
oh I don't look at the bird you idiot
yeah that's an agent bird
dude it's a dress look what's that call
is at the paradise house where all the
mechanical birds like oh no I got this
from the shop man yeah I know right
outside the paradise bird cave beautiful
though
what would you special oriental colors
did you wait in the lines like a
civilian or did you have that VIP I got
the pass
yeah you got it bro it was expensive and
it was an investment but I got wholly
worthless so huh had to get it couldn't
yeah the kids start fist fight and
choking each other you'll have a family
that starts the line with four kids in
the line with two kids bro bro first of
all happy place on earth is the biggest
scam of all time
every parent's miserable also does
everyone that didn't have to be obese
why isn't one so fat on scooters are
there oh you know there is a lot of yeah
I so scootering going on I saw a couple
thick rigs and a couple of [ __ ] doubt
Ron is out there racing each other dude
in those [ __ ] do one guy got stuck on
kind of an incline and he just literally
was just like could it wasn't moving he
had full blast clogged artery he thought
he's on clogged artery Mountain you guys
go on the cars ride no oh you didn't oh
damn I didn't go to California venture I
just went to Disneyland so but we had a
good time man it was a you know it was a
lot of
my thing is they sell they have a gift
shop at every turn that's how they get
the parents bro you're in the toilet you
leave dude I walked into the bathroom
when I walked out they moved a gift shop
in front of the door and they were
selling all this toilet stuff big brown
you have no idea without them bro my
hands get all sticky and this got
[ __ ] food there too it's weird dude
I don't let you down at Disneyland bro
I'm never wear a [ __ ] Mickey hat at
this point man give me the costume for
[ __ ] sake this is great though yeah oh
one question at a time first of all
there's no way you're gonna fit into a
Mickey costume okay you'll be more like
thicky Mouse okay and there goes our
meme for the week right there Mouse and
don't be somebody that is eating and
doing duty at the same time bro the
haunted mansion brother I don't care did
you go on Pirates of Caribbean Johnny
Depp you don't let both your holes work
at the same time it's beautiful it's
busy relax cribbing yeah he doesn't have
a gig now so he just sits and pretend
it's pretty dope dude that's crazy start
taking pastry cuz they thought your
[ __ ] Tinker Bell idea was that funny
actually uh no dude all I'm saying is I
got this traditional garb that I wore
back the worst [ __ ] ride in the
goddamn amusement park they're getting
rid of that they're gonna bulldoze that
[ __ ] a paradise [ __ ] bird talk
you sit in there oh no they gotta step
up the game man you've been that's right
before I eat cakes bro hey K you've been
eating a batch of [ __ ] hot fingers
Sammy's bro you gotta back off the anger
sandwiches man that place is dope though
damn well is it or isn't man you're
[ __ ] in the rise hold on
I'm [ __ ] on the haunted house not a
ride okay haunted house okay know your
[ __ ] point I'm trying to think of what
else seemed like I always like I
remember going there on LSD when I was
in high school yeah and uh and it was
definitely oh that was Disney World
actually but it was fun
Disney were some also made love to my
girlfriend on the Greyhound bus taking a
beat out of your book can smear taking a
beat from behind with your girlfriend
the Greyhound bus to Disney World Disney
World that Center was that Kanye's or
worse [ __ ] Department Epcot they've
liked the taste of Germany and England
and [ __ ] oh my god really oh dude it's
the whole world go to tasting England do
to [ __ ] your teeth up I know that taste
enough of it fish and chips and you put
yellow teeth yeah and if fish have bones
in them dude they're eating the bones
over there yeah I've caught some vessel
I'm like what's happening we're like
yeah talk yeah I'm little salty today oh
yeah bro where you been hanging out dude
in the salt mines you just come from
Salt Lake City bro
wow man what happened over the weekend
Derek's dad pissed you off
oh I'm on a new diet are you new diet
and I've had sugar carbs in 13 days now
really oh yeah that'll get you dude try
doing this try to change it you're Anna
depressants changing your
antidepressants alright going on keto
and uh just smoking cigarettes at night
that's what you were doing doing for two
years and you will [ __ ] kill yourself
in the bathtub dude I don't know man I
thought it comes up like six times dude
they just don't make rope like this bro
these new kids with the [ __ ] new rope
you know it's all breakaway ropes you
can't hang yourself
the yellow colors the neon colors old
grounds
oh yeah give me that big brown around my
neck baby you feel me let's get into it
man can do it - dude going to paid abuse
do bro transformations important part of
our lives and careers we you and I we're
always evolving dude we're always
evolving we're growing
I am I kind of am I'm not actually I'm
trying but do you know why man that's
what makes life interesting in our
sponsor for this is wicks they invite
you to tell the story of your career and
transformation like Theo
whether it's remand a woman whatever it
is visually transform by design your new
homepage on wigs I'm actually we're
building a site right now on wigs Oh
dope men so pretty stoked about that
well you could join the competition it's
a cool competition we're encouraging
King and the sting listeners to build
their most imaginative creative homepage
a homepage that highlights why your
career journey is unique just like you
yeah Wix is the free platform that
empowers you to build highly
customizable robust websites and robust
a robust again roam on Wix offers
hundreds of templates so hundreds of you
know different setups and designs
unlimited pages and top-grade hosting
for free check out Wix editor here on
screen it offers you these drag and drop
tools to create a fantastic website
quickly and efficiently if you have a
business or something you want to get
your who you are or what your product is
across to somebody Wix is the way to do
it man I wish I'd known about Wix when I
was building my website just quicker
it's so nice yeah
dude back to the competition please well
tell them yes so let's get back to
competition just go to wix.com slash go
slash katz to start your own Wix website
for free and submit the link of your
home page to Wix loves cats at gmail.com
yep that's WI X LOV es que ATS at
gmail.com submit the link of your new
home page and we will review the
and announce the grand prize winner of
the wicks business VIP premiere plan Wow
free for one year a value of $420 once
again that's URL is wix.com slash go
slash cats and submit the link of your
homepage to Wix loves cats at gmail.com
yep good luck guys and we're excited to
to look at the submissions gang gang
buzz buzz trying to keep lights on dude
sometimes I'm like man I'm starving but
I want a nice watch try want nice
sunglasses yeah what's funny is you seem
exactly like that person I know that's
hungry I mean like it easily get you
know next thing you know you'll you'll
eat a watch like if I saw some cool
shades or like I'm starving but those
shades are very expensive I want those
I'll have to do it anymore man cuz you
don't have to decide between eating or
sunglasses
thanks to movement MV MT movement
sunglasses yep it's a los angeles-based
accessory brand have hundreds of premium
affordable sunglass styles to choose
from so whether you're into more
timeless shapes like classic round
Sony's or something I'm selling yeah you
could look like Tom Selleck you could
look like Tom's sellout you could look
like whoever you want bro Pinkett Tom
you have two constructed with durable
acetate and lightweight materials for
the perfect reliable fit with free
shipping free returns policy you can try
as many sunglasses you want right from
your home free shipping free returns
pick a style and design you like and
would wear and you can even chat about
it on their site if you need more
details you can hit them up and let them
know all our polarized lenses as well so
you don't have to worry about that Sun
ruining your day also movement
sunglasses start at 60 bucks no Pierre
price is over 95 so you're guaranteed to
find a style you love with quality that
doesn't break the bank bro they've sold
over 2.5 million products across more
than 160 countries
MVM tea movement get 15% off today get
that hitter right now get that deal free
shipping free return just a Sun out your
grill see why movement keeps growing
check out the expanding collection right
now go to MVM t.com slash cat
k 80s yep join the movement go to nvm
t.com / k 80s join the movement
get those face hitters gang support the
podcast you know what I think I'm gonna
start with a little roast my host this
week let's see what they've been saying
is we've been ripping a bra still can't
believe we ripped that one bald-headed
mechanic guy that looked like he was
working fixing Satan's truck probably
that guy'll throw a wrench in the World
Trade Center bro that guy in the
basement this first one oh my god
Brennan looks like he draws his beard on
every day but never has enough time to
finish looks like character on that
thing where you move the metal over soon
just came in first of all like somebody
who purposely crashed the computers just
so he could come in and say it and then
fix him I never mind
here it is like you're welcome yeah so
he could save the day dude he's kind of
like he's just turned it seemed like
somebody that's playing in the trouble
just so they can be in the trouble you
know a lot of killers they'll kill
somebody then they'll come by and be
like hey what happened let's go on a
search let's go on a search and figure
it out yeah that's gonna sit over here
yeah so Chin's doing right now dude
we've seen a thousand times yeah we've
seen fooling anybody chin you know I'm
starting to get worried though why is he
doing that
I don't think cuz uh because Derek and
Catherine here and he's not what's going
on I don't want to turn into like that
Selena type of that lady that killed
Selena sure about the manager Marga lead
or whatever it lays yes y'all jealous a
little Ricky whatever that lady's name
was her name's little tamale Fatima
which is until Selena bro who is it
never you look it up for this dude I'm
saying [ __ ] in a hotel in Portland I'm
[ __ ] nervous I could just see I've
just been noticing about him he seemed a
little bit more on his own merch that's
not weird really is it that's that's
exactly what Selena's manager did start
selling her own merch saying she's the
manager to the stars oh you know they
get off a bus she shoots her yeah
under Saldivar I'm sure that [ __ ] got
beat up in prison - Yolanda Saldivar
mm-hmm oh my god she that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh Selena was from straight thicker agua
bro Selena that's the killer you'll
understand well let's lean on the right
dose Selena had that peach cobbler out
the back Oh bra is cheat oh hi cage boy
put some syrup on that but baby yeah I
just found just getting worried about
Jenny but now he's like powers out
Computers down yeah
and cut thank you yeah he also gave this
Star Trek hand signal too when he did it
Computers down and his glasses I'm like
you're not on set bro
yeah man thinking of Porter cheek Landy
a Portlandia my boy ass on whatever city
we go until we get tinder you know for
him cuz he can assign to your other
opener dangerous Brown yeah oh yeah
small seen that guy [ __ ] honest I've
reported that guy a couple times so if
he has two strikes on his record at
least one of them's from me that's fair
I always keep a close eye on him on a
separate plane first I tried to I tried
it we just can't you can tell them hey
if you're coming it's on a different
plane he always I go I maybe ditch the
backpack hey yeah maybe leave the
backpack at home yeah maybe the front
pack and also the Koran tattooed on your
[ __ ] back maybe get it removed also
is that a Raiders flag or an Isis flag
we never know oh yeah but he met her you
met up Nicky Nashville really Vicki
Henderson huh got you sliding in the
[ __ ] second base at the buffet he
would slide into the [ __ ] third base
hit the buffet she was he got a chunky
fly in his web
did he oh he got a Klondike bar I'm
talking about
Oh thick like gravy there's no like you
had a girl in the back in your hand kind
of bounces off oh I like that too I like
that
I don't mind look at that girl's good I
like a thick girl as long as it's that
strong thick I don't like that little
muscle under the layer of fat you know
I'm saying kind of like I like my ribs
well some girls fat has muscle in it
I like that marbled woman do you know
what I don't want to get ribeye [ __ ]
well what I don't like is when you just
get that you know that gristle e gristle
only yeah you know and I like the skirt
steak either you know I'm saying where
they're too skinny
yeah I like that like you said like that
marble rib eye [ __ ] yeah I like them
cuz I like that desert fat a little bit
that's the thing about the Kardashians
they got that that that that desert fair
they got that Persian [ __ ] spark on
me yeah they got that sand that there's
a little bit of sand in the fact them
try to tip tip yeah it's like a little
hard fat I don't you know it's got to be
strong you can't just have little haunts
on the back yeah you came to be having a
bunch of eaters milling around with a
bunch of extra titties in the front you
think back yeah but a summit he meets
girls and he's just he's just striking
out and needy yeah man he's trying but
is he crazy strikes out hard yeah but he
can do small guy
oh yeah heat his eyes only Wow mount it
freaks him out bro I could see that a
little but dude he caught that chunky
Klondike bar in his web didn't took her
home he almost had her man he got her to
him was hotter we sound like [ __ ]
puree talking about
that's why you got to put a grill in
your apartment brought some ladies like
a snack at night especially the thick
ones like that do door just open out
your [ __ ] fries and have the variety
pack of Klondike bars they got all sorts
you do for a Klondike bar
what would you do for a Klondike bar
hopefully hopefully suck this dick well
that's what I saw was thinking yeah
probably dude who knows he might want to
[ __ ] plot it you know the end of the
world whether he might be thinking oh
this girl could carry a bomb you won't
want that sand mule yeah he threw the
airport oh he's hunting that little
[ __ ] dynamite donkey brother a bomb
huh
he's somebody to mule that TNT for
anything stick Rhonda could do it they
crowned me with the fireworks but is
staying away from the fact that Brendan
looks like that [ __ ] character the
character called Derek you have that
Eric's about to lose his [ __ ] job of
Wally Willy yeah you look like woolly
woolly Willy Jesus Christ people know
what two O's in a row mean that's Eric
Griffin first of all first of all let's
be honest Harry's parents designed him
off of a [ __ ] shitty game okay
apparently Eric Griffin's mom [ __ ] a
woolly Willy wow I wasn't gonna say that
part so there has to be one looks like
we're ending in there yeah all right
god that's spot-on in it that eyepatch
man oh you know that send me an eyepatch
oh yeah you should bring it back I'll
bring it back probably and once winter
comes look better with one eye what else
we got
we got one person that said it feels
actually bald that's just a parrot on
his head
just a cockatoo yes because somebody the
other day came and put some birdseed up
on my scalp Brennan is like a sleazy
limo driver it's on the bride on the way
to the result I yeah so you sure you
want to do oh I could take you guys I
get to show you some other stuff around
town today you're in the Klondike
[Laughter]
Brennan looks like he's playing Jack
Sparrow in the gay porn remake of
Pirates of the Caribbean off Sparrow man
Wow Black Jack putting syrup on your
buddy it looks like you pressure losses
well the pressure washes waffle houses
for some categories [ __ ] molest this
bride-to-be now it's everyone's favorite
time it's a commercial from King in the
state I'm your sell online bro getting
your orders can be a real pain like you
buy something in a steaming pain right
now because I've been trying to sell
online dude you're not using ship
station you need ship station it's the
fastest easiest most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders don't die on
me bro don't die me man oh man what tell
me more man I'm dying
I'll try my best ship station helps you
get orders out quickly you save money on
shipping costs and keep your customers
happy as a clam
no matter where you're selling Amazon
whatever it is your own website like
King and the sting ship station brings
you all your orders onto a simple
interface making it so it's interface oh
man now I'm lightheaded because I'm not
using it let me take over take it ship
station works with all the major
carriers including USPS FedEx UPS Kevin
Costner in the mailman even Amazon
Fulfillment Tom Cruise so you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution for you and your customer quit
looking through all of the [ __ ] online
you're out of your mind bras gonna take
half the day you're gonna make nine
dollars doing the package waiting for
Morgan Freeman to drop off your package
substation is number one choice of
online sellers just ship more and less
time with the best rates available yeah
hit him with the discount dude discount
I'm King and the sting listeners right
now can try ship station for free for 60
days when you use promo code Kay 80s
there's absolutely no risk you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info just visit ship
station which is pretty much like that
car they got submitted that van with the
boat on the back if it was also a ship
but yet a station it just ship station
calm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage type in K 80s that ship
station comm enter promo code K 80s ship
station calm make [ __ ] happen knock
knock who's there an advertisement in
dock Ginga Noah
indogene oh dang indogene oh look a a I
say you need better fitting suit all-pro
endowed Chino is Asian you don't link
when bro yeah why is your globe only
have two countries on it dude
cuz that's what I was raised right not
either asian-american do endo Chino
they have endo tchen no no what depends
how you put it if you go into Chino Road
they got like yes nice science is the
point they got nice suits they get to
measure suits bro bro you sending your
measure
and they got the soup boom what do you
win I'm indogene no papa
in the gin visit a stylist at the
showroom over 40 showrooms all around
North America and have them take your
measurements personally or do it
yourself do it online send it in a tin
to Tino dot-com choose your fabric
choose your design submit your
measurements boom you're looking like a
dime piece off The Sopranos when that
suit comes in this week you guys can get
any premium into Chino suit for 369 got
a wedding coming got a funeral whatever
dude somebody's making a new baklava
show up in style with that indogene Oh
full body swag style that's 50% off the
regular price for made-to-measure
premium suits plus shipping is always
free that's in duty no calm promo code
cats for any premium suit for just 369
buck and get one for the baby take the
baby in there they measure the baby up
be 14 inches tall who gives a [ __ ]
computer than of suing confuse the
family you and your girl wear the same
suit do NSA mix it up put that little
baby in a suit like on that movie if you
see baby ya mus be like a boss baby all
you should wear the same suit get a
discount go to NDG know.com promote okay
ATM any premium suit for three hundred
and sixty nine dollars just three
hundred $69 and free shipping you know
what they say once you go custom you
never go back
yeah quit looking like [ __ ] get that
Indo Chino suit buzz buzz don't got to
pay for Till's haircut all right we'll
start with a little shine my ride boys
when we segment don't [ __ ] we've been
doing is there's some [ __ ] troubled
animals out yeah makes you realize how
[ __ ] up dogs are still can't get that
one with that [ __ ] orange leg out of
my mind how about the cat with one
[ __ ] I hold his brother illegally
parked here hey which one of the [ __ ]
Nelly boys is this this is Damon Mouse
and it's purple Jeep boys D Mouse out
there damn D Mouse with that purple
grape hitter damn you look again this is
very Rome and very look it is very Roman
no Roman I've ever seen very Houston ish
if you feel me oh yeah no your New
Orleans didn't say where he's from but
it look like every car in the gas
station at the Indianapolis place oh it
did you talking about the black Expo oh
boy I got that purple lights too it
looks like you drank a bunch of scissor
and then bought this Jeep online and now
I want to know cat when the winner when
unique women like yourself when you guys
see got this kind of deal what are you
guys is something that's sexy and your
culture is just not your vibe what do
you jump in and share a rack of ribs
with them
no only because of the rim something is
very off yeah about the rims yeah no
[ __ ] Brendon I asked at thank you guys I
could kind of work with everything else
it's the rims that's a stranger danger
yeah I feel you yeah they have that
scream strip club owner yes yes yeah the
Rams are to their religious a little
outdated we need some type of new rim or
something totally new spinner yeah Amir
spinners oh those were dope that would
truck the car would stop the wheels keep
on spinning baby they didn't seem like
it's we're kind of in a time where there
should be something new like with the
tires some of these rims you look a
little bit they all look the same don't
they like with this great hitter he has
there you got to put those real 4x4
wheels on a Jeep dude you can't be
buying that thing then this thing looks
like my son's [ __ ] Tonka truck well
let's zoom back out if he had regular
wheels on that [ __ ] dude he just looks
like a homosexual nah you think I think
so dude I knew disrespect bro you don't
the same I'm gonna be gay one day
according to Brendan you know just what
age depends how hard your life get but I
think dude you put some 4x4 wheels on
there that [ __ ] be crawling over you
put a surfboard on the bags that jared
leto we don't know
surfboard dude this guy might die in the
water bro don't know what's going on
saying it's racist duty personnel you
don't put a handicapped guy out in the
water where you write you write she lays
this dude you want to talk about Jaws
bro what do you Brendon I love it good
thing you're not a movie director man
why is that if you did jaws for you know
designed by Brendan would be a couple of
handicapped dudes out there wall around
it should be a short movie then we
didn't have to worry about the Sharks it
would be called oz because he had watch
you like oh Sam to a tattoos no sharks
one wave is a rap bro dude what the hey
homeboy here with [ __ ] Nelly screw
with the Jeep I'm not mad at the grape
color also he looks at like he goes
around [ __ ] schools giving out those
great Mike and Ikes you know I'm talking
about yeah those are my favorite just
grapes they still make them big Mike I
do those the guard in the pay the grape
ones are good what candy was horrible
was the one it looked like banner drills
or something on the box the way the box
was oh good and plenties uh-huh those
are my favorite now [ __ ] is it English
people like there's plenty I love how
that's an advertised negative here's a
bunch of it there was a shitload of them
though they ain't lyin
they're horrible courser was dude hey
this is horrible have a lot of it you
fell for them marketing I did they got
me bro dude look dude you ever had a you
ever had remember the what were the hot
ones were they're hot as [ __ ] they're
super hot like oh [ __ ] describe them
again not saying hot not ear heads
noting the command cat that's what I was
gonna guess which was a great it guess
right nope they're like super hot come
on they are like fireball nope come on
man you don't know if we don't even want
to know it we don't even want to know
what it is and you're for my fireballs
nope let's just move on yeah give me the
next [ __ ] shitty whip I almost want
chin to pop back anyway telling us
something's down
again date the whip that picture also
looks like it could be from like eight
years ago
like oh we got Jack may gotten the guy
jacket and the guy taking about you kill
me you say that yeah my end you know I
mean this dude these things what
nightmares are made of
also just cuz they sell at Pep Boys
doesn't you have to put on your [ __ ]
oh hey get this new vanilla Senate door
you know you could hang it off the side
of your van this this looks like we're
seal took his family to Disneyland
closet Disneyland
but it is that thing you think about red
door first of all if you are not
watching this on youtube you are missing
out seven hundred percent because it's
the greatest house I've ever seen there
okay so mobile home one lawsuit with the
wifey and this is where you live be
right here huh yeah you ain't put some
22s on that bit so you don't know saying
I put some spinners on it where's that
door to lead to and what I want to know
the in style I don't think so but they
make sense go take a heart good habits
row in Vietnam and she would come in
very handy because they the land gets
flooded there every year and they have
to rebuild their house so you could just
drive your house off a couple of you
know out of the water right here do the
back of the aircraft yeah yeah this is a
hovercraft I don't know man this looks
like you ever seen taxicab confessions
the pornos look might be a glory hole in
the back there look at that what's that
good lead to I got a lot of glory holes
dude a glory hallway there is a [ __ ]
door
first of all this door goes above the
top of the vans on sale if you open the
door it doesn't make sense at all this
looks like a third graders drawing and
someone just was like yeah I'll build
that oh whatever Bernie you don't know
anything about carpentry do you do have
any more facts about this vehicle no we
have no facts about there's nothing
nothing we have nine people working on
the show we have zero facts about this
homeboy didn't send any fax doesn't
anyone know where the [ __ ] is at guys
it's so the van there's a front door on
the van and then right next to the front
door there is a red door to a train out
of it yeah there's a red door to a home
and it is there's actually the side of a
home is taped to the edge of the bed
legit tape like the blue tape I love the
window right there is that a door yeah
oh man all right we close it or hey we
unlock the door man emergence you god
this is Noah's [ __ ] Park bro this
thing has a [ __ ] emergency brake on
it and could take a maximum amount of
animals so confusing oh this is what men
and women are nowadays this thing could
use a transgender restroom that's for
damn sure that's the thing do we even
call this a vehicle I'm sure has a bunch
of pronouns it's a she hick will
probably dude this thing baby is
wherever it wants bro is that it's hid
is that a tire who knows the hoods
painted blue for no trees it's
definitely neutral oh yeah there's
obviously blood inside of it wow this is
like Dexter's going on vacation let's
get out of here their support the
podcast here's an ad well Brendon you
know what you know how to dude oh I
noticed row and you're not gonna live
forever dude especially dressing like a
six year old yeah I hear you man you got
a Disneyland t-shirt on and I want to
talk to you for something
life insurance yeah nobody bolt should
look into it you know I was living very
long oh not long at all bro I mean
especially get out of hung
beyond the wall the other day well
there's an earthquake let's kill me yeah
I feel yeah listen almost kill me almost
lost my life do you want to see a little
bit of investigative discovery on 64
inches ght 64 inches that worth your
life I don't think so listen you need
life insurance dude that's why policy
genius is easy way to shop for life
insurance online in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the right amount of coverage at the best
price possible
yep the policy genius policy genius
starting to sound like you team can look
at your workplace
life insurance policy and help you
decide what else you might need and what
you don't you might be getting a bunch
of insurance for something you can't
even do you live in a desert and they
got you you spending $30 a month on
timber falling on you that's crazy buddy
crazy buddy head to policy genius.com
today and find out how to supplement
your workplace life insurance and better
protect your family policy genius it's
like a buffet made of life insurance and
what could be more delicious than that
that's right head of policy genius.com
today know if you need Timber know if
you need scorpion coverage fire flood
you know I'm saying alien bro for two
extra dollars get the alien package dude
you know genius.com yeah man it's like a
buffet made a life insurance policy
genius comm check it out knock-knock
who's there hey the old bread then we'll
do a little debate club next get back to
where we know that's the worst vehicle
we've ever had on here that is quite a
vehicle man first this is Alex from st.
Louis Alex looks like Gail's old worker
that used to work as a fighter in the
kid what was that girl's name I don't
know but you and her have the same nose
that's my sister you're coming to see
you in Memphis we are so excited we're
driving all the way from st. Louis to
come see you so I guarantee it's gonna
be hilarious yeah we love you guys
recently okay you guys are definitely
related somehow and
young lady uh Brendan with so basically
looking at your teen even hear your
question can't we play it you know me
too well
between her nose and the tips have no
idea Alex some about ribs I have a
question for you I am a gamer all day
every day but I am a PlayStation girl so
what do you think it's better Xbox or
Playstation vo my sister and I are
coming to see you in Memphis we are so
excited we're driving all the way from
st. Louis to come see you so I guarantee
it's gonna be hilarious we love you guys
Gang Gang buzz buzz girl Congrats on the
nose
why are you making fun of her no she's
I'm married I think you guys both have
nice noses you call me potato nose all
the time you text me sometimes to say
hey man hurt your breathing really well
[Music]
and you'll often you'll text also this
is a something I've noticed and you'll
say instead of no K you know wo write in
OSE and then you'll [ __ ] say it was a
type of like an iPhone bro I'm thinking
both have nice noses okay we'll say that
and your cousins come to see and you
guys should split some nice Memphis ribs
well look you had tits in your ears the
first time you can't even hear the woman
and she seemed like a lovely lady and I
look I love all these chick gamers man I
like seeing this Playstation or Xbox for
me it's PlayStation Xbox looks like
you're working for pharmaceutical sales
or something that thing's too [ __ ]
big
you know it's white you can't hide it
that easily Xbox is black Xbox Xbox is
bladder-control white right they come in
both colors they're not when I was a kid
is blast the Xbox the Xbox started off
as black the first one was black
PlayStation was it light gray here's the
thing Xbox all day cuz the Xbox
controller is big so she can deal with
that Xbox controllers can deal with this
dick we keep that touch me the
PlayStation small go get back in your
[ __ ] boat van and [ __ ] do that
prime you know idea could someone yeah
you're the one who's flying a [ __ ]
little brat a couple of brown guys
on the country the [ __ ] no I don't hear
you Doug I'm talking about you Derek I'm
actually just talking about the other
guy the [ __ ] killer you still have
dangerous brows
yeah dangerous right not your [ __ ]
buddy man I'm joking I like you Sony's a
sweet guy yeah but we don't trust him
you play video games though right
I play call of duty right now and I play
it by myself people keep asking me to
get on their team and [ __ ] dude I gotta
[ __ ] sleep I ain't tryin to [ __ ] be
talking to some men in different
countries as [ __ ] at night yeah I
probably could I thought I had one in
here until you [ __ ] made fun of me am
i sit both of my sisters from Memphis
okay feel like you and your sisters and
here's some trouble in Memphis we're
walking in Memphis where that Jam do
won't you reload your marks a lot and
finish putting your face on brother okay
it's on the same with that scattered
hair dude looks like a full grow a
complete beard what was she asking him
okay what's this buckle bunny talking
dude buckle bunnies a fun term for
people that go to rodeo sorry buckle
buddy yeah I'm gonna go to the radio
soon as I'm done pressure washing I
don't play video game stuff but I grew
up with Xbox
was like the vein business you could
start bruh if you [ __ ] her up in a poor
environment
practice your wall [ __ ] that was the
moon dude that was like Ukraine an app
at Harvard change is like he's got his
own press room or don't make this you
tell me pressure washing company yeah
he's [ __ ] bro
so shout-out to anybody who's out there
P dubbing dude [ __ ] yeah and look both
of my niece's can come to the show and
I'll say this PlayStation it just looks
swag ear
I'm not turning on a [ __ ] Xbox plus
I'm a pedophile bro pedal Xboxes for me
seem like they're more in that pedophile
culture PlayStation to me seems a little
bit more fine dining if you will it's
for people with small hands okay I'll
take that 55% went with Playstation
bro you're an idiot I win this one dish
that out to the [ __ ] Wow you're the
kind of guy that hits all the buttons
are on a table don't even what they're
doing it's called button mashing up next
we got Brian from Sulphur Louisiana gang
bruh Eric Griffin's let's see you know
taste Rijo gang bruh a little too much
energy for some that's where let me know
guys keep doing what you're doing
much low buzz buzz bang gang bang bang
first of all I thought I heard women
chained up in the back of his videos it
was a little weird it's either a woman
on he's running a slave to calm for me
that you can tell he's he would see he
parked and stepped into the back of the
house boat video what was the question
date a blind girl or a deaf girl what
was so easy deaf really yeah I got a do
deaf why I'm gonna ruin your whole no
one's gonna like you know we don't have
to be honest I would go deaf cuz you
wanted to see things you just don't want
the deaf girl talking all the time first
of all yes I do know what you think you
felt for the [ __ ] be honest Chris and
boy Jimmy and now you're going down
bunny yeah you fell for the be honest
quicksand bro you thought I'm gonna hold
you up in a bucket took you down boy
dude here's the thing blind girls can
just think whatever you want what you
tell them what's going on that's the
thing about blonds you get to be that
liaison you get to be that [ __ ] color
that color donkey form
maybe that the eye Walker dog for him
yeah do your [ __ ] Pablo Picasso all
day you know you could describe
something to him if you if you totally
look like Bradley Cooper Baruch like
feel Vaughn do we had a guy a cousin I
think I don't know somebody was [ __ ]
but
um we told him there were dragons
outside that's fair and he thought there
were dude and until you seen a blind kid
hide from a dragon you know can't live
bro you haven't seen anything in an open
field that's I know well look man this
is a different times man this one kids
you know kids that you know we're more
imagination you know so I would say
blind if I did date a blind woman or a
deaf woman I think I would prefer blind
because I think they seem more patient
you get to walk them around a little bit
you're taking a baseball games and light
them say it's the ninth inning what's
the second you could say yes front row
seat take it always be one we won but
you she thinks your team's undefeated
yeah deaf girl might get pissed you got
shitty seats all the time at an event
and you got to learn sign language
rather I think if we're gonna go to a
female's perspective would you rather be
would you rather date a blind or deaf
guy I think I'd rather date a deaf guy
personally I just have a deep bass voice
and I of people assume that I'm a butch
woman which is fine perfectly fine I
just think I have better chances of
dating a deaf guy than I would a blind
guy oh wow I don't but the blind guy
might go like this you know I'm saying
like that's how they they feel they just
and they paint but I blog I can also
feel you that's what I'm saying a deaf
guy can also feel you though
yeah but he can see yeah that's true
Derrick what do you think what do you go
blind girls give the best blow jobs and
they can imagine that dick is anything
baby you know what I mean anything yeah
but bigs big you know I'm saying they
high-five like they're from [ __ ]
little rats go do you see them high five
[ __ ] yeah bro you can't high five
it's a blind people dude it's not cool I
know you're talking about off the whole
Coulter corner high-five each other with
their club going on god oh
we need shin right now to blast this off
into a different galaxy man but uh good
luck out there and sulphur brother yeah
either blind or deaf good work man
sulphur beautiful city sixty percent
went with death as well deaf girls yeah
that's tough man when the pine alright
boys a little relationship advice of me
oh I do we're just making the world
better every episode who would hit us up
a relationship advice awesome beauty but
I'm looking for a [ __ ] a lot of
people yeah you're right that's pretty
good call what else what do you got here
this is from Joseph from Columbus Ohio
yes it Joseph okay yeah like the
Frederick Douglass attended make sure
the story's not as long as this one
whatever you do buzz buzz dog I would
tell the truth I got a couple of shows
found that wife uh [ __ ] the Asian
ordered bride you didn't mean on tinder
bro what are we doing tenders definitely
is basically like it
you can get it you can get every type of
people space like farmersonly.com but
for everyone not just for whites yeah
it's for ya you could also you know this
is a real step I think 60 or 70% of
relationships in 2018 start off-site you
made that out whatever I'm saying you
can look it up anywhere and you made it
up but what I'm saying is this first of
all the guy okay
the guy is making a video while he's
driving with his wife and child okay
this is where you met cuz you know where
you're gonna unmeet a funeral place me
my wife news your wife can sit in the
front seat bro it is 2019 you guys met
overseas bro no man I do get that he has
a military type of vibe and there's
nothing wrong with that either and he
also he obviously has that asian that
yellow fever they call it you know I
think no that's a different that's a
disease that killed a lot of people are
thinking they know yellow fever is fine
look up yellow fever four is Derek I'm
pretty sure yellow fevers are real look
wooly Willy just dragged some more hair
on your face with your little stencil or
the name of Coldplay's fan base yellow
fever what is it Derek it's a reading
fast I don't sound racist you got a
disease caused by a virus that is spread
through mosquito bites and that's what
I'm talking about
not yellow fever is a real thing dude if
you like just Asian yeah you got yellow
fever yeah that fear cut it's absolutely
fair it's fair see you're not racist not
racist at all and so how does it
encompasses yellow fever only Japanese
people are kind of whitish I think yeah
some Asians look really white and others
look really brown Filipinos are super
dark yeah oh yeah Filipino Grigio how
nobody's come out with that wine yet
never understand yeah why don't we
market that Filipino Grigio how about
yellow wine are you Filipino
uh no Vietnamese well look let's tell
people you're Filipino and make them all
sell it oh let's let's say you smashed
the grapes with your feet and sell the
wine what people love her feet dude oh
yeah and then buy one get one free and
you get a bus lamp
slam peas that demand is so high why
broke having a little bit of communal
bust in the living room why do I go all
to your separate rooms to jerk off you
know what I'm saying it's 2019 living
room like a vikin like a real crew you
know like a real family problem should
he keep it quiet about tinder that where
they met because that's what his wife
hates or should he talk about it because
they made what do you think being it's a
good question man listen just just say
you met at a bar who gives a [ __ ] who
cares but that's not what he's asking
and family's older like his families are
they don't know what tinder is they
don't know what Instagram is so you have
to explain all that a little white lies
not bad like we met at a bar yeah we're
married now [ __ ] you know I'm saying
like get over it I don't know that seems
aggressive it seemed like a way it's
like a berry mom is he's driving and
[ __ ] recording this nine-hour
question that's the biggest he's going
90 miles an hour and then was super
creepy girls this is my wife dude first
of all I love a creepy dude okay
I work with one second of all I uh I
think but here's the thing if you want
to tell the just don't make the reason
you do it to like make funny or wife or
something if she feels uncomfortable
saying you met at the mall this kind of
[ __ ] 94 I guess II the mall so you met
at a nice fancy restaurant at the bar
some [ __ ] yeah yeah least make it
somewhere nice maybe like the Holiday
Inn had a UH they always have a club at
the Holiday Inn like a little bar called
like celebrations or you know uh you
know uproar it always has a shitty name
you met at Waffle House no that's a good
kind of Waffle House no one hates on it
there's no perfect place to meet I don't
think is there a perfect place to meet
let's go to the culture corner because
the mall though we know that yeah
definitely not a mall especially now I
feel like malls or where older guys go
pick up highschool girls dude oh yeah
yeah you're probably right here's the
other thing about tinder this is us
excess story I'm not on tinder you
probably are but all they say is it's a
hook-up site dudes are just busting nuts
left and right trying to make these
lamps no one's getting married hey there
success story they got married off
tinder that's dope well is it saying
stream he said they're a success story
he says they're a success and I say yeah
look I think yeah just [ __ ] I don't know
tinder should use them for marketing
everyone trying to [ __ ] bust nuts and
spread diseases on tinder these people
are real they met on there they got a
family now he's driving 90 miles an hour
in his [ __ ] Outback Subaru on the
road filming it's a success I think a
look tell your boys you met on tinder
that's fine I think if she wants to have
some different airs for her family you
could tell them that and then you know
and that can be that and come up with a
cool place though it's hard to keep that
lie all the goddamn time yeah that's a
thing
so you met at a chili do what Chili's
yeah everybody meets a Chili's dude they
got chips they got [ __ ] steak baby
back they have no ovens in the back
everything's been in a microwave and
they bring it out like it was made in an
oven bro yeah dude that's America dude
so tell them this where you met who see
Mehta Marie Callender's because we run
out of business let your wife sell
questions yeah let your wife sit in the
front seat every now and then dude yeah
yeah she's not Rosa Parks eat all right
yeah let's start there and then worry
about the family's judgement she's not
[ __ ] our Alsop party you know Rosa
Park else we got all right we got a
little a little flaw my aunt up next
yeah let's see some bed me on these
finances he's some man first we have
aunt Cindy Oh God it starts with sin ooh
is this Punk my own no it's for my arm
oh hell yeah horses in the bag
talk about a buckle bunny what's up girl
look at that riding those meats buckle
Rhonda check it out man you're not
[ __ ] around these uncle bunnies are
hot
and can we zoom in on any of these uh so
we can get a look at the lady is this
the same person or did she morph into an
uncle this is the same really this is
not offended just because a woman's
tougher than you doesn't mean they're a
man Brenda
okay that's why your her buckle bunny
yeah it's off that horse she's sucking
tits
dude uh well does she have a wedding
ring on nope do we know anything about
her Derek where are you guys getting
these women Cindy is the hardest working
lady uh hardest working lady that this
young lady a man knows nice nose still
rides horses and has over 20 rescues at
her ranch owns a ranch and she has three
daughters oh yeah and you know you a
real bad woman when you only make other
women with your vagina you memory
daughters yes sir that's crazy bro you
got a really you got a step at night and
just roll those eggs in your body you
know and I know her husband's when she
gets on better I've dinner ready better
have dinner a house better be clean
assless chaps I'm making dinner
Oh dishes in the washer casserole in the
oven
oh this lady seemed like she'll
breastfeed herself if she has to she and
waiting around for no [ __ ] now she
don't need no man me two movements a
[ __ ] what right a horse yeah me who bro
she have a cowboy ride a horse she
that's her life slogan he's a tough gal
yeah Cindy ain't playing
and she goes after it and uh and I like
it I applaud you flaunting this lady
look at her right there one of the
animals almost looks dead that she's
riding on the far right yeah the far
right one looks like you might have yeah
he said man I can't handle it anymore
don't do you see I can't live like this
Cindy I'm exhausted you're on me every
goddamn day you never let me ride
straight turns only I'm out I'm out
turns only on a horse Wow going in seven
I'll see you at Elmer's dog here's a loo
me up Scotty
here's the thing if [ __ ] aunt Amy or
the [ __ ] Andy is her name [ __ ]
Vance Cindy and feel fought in a knock
gun she'd be a minus 3000 right now with
her calloused hands really into your
stupid face [ __ ] yeah is that who wins
yes all my face is stupid sorry I'm just
saying she scares me you know I'm saying
she ought to rougher for my liking well
look man then don't stick around me dude
I bet I could handle or I would take her
out in a nice no you ain't you ain't the
van house
you ain't the one for her she looks like
she she thought [ __ ] Brokeback
Mountain was a comedy she's a tough lady
thank you we're happy to flaunt her man
hell yeah flaunt that bad damn
making women only with your vagina
that's gangster I didn't need a guy
I dare you to try to get a boy out of
this I bet she does that tattooed on ur
inner thighs
it says no boys yeah next we got Aunt
Jenny yeah but then she don't have a pug
for a daughter all that Chihuahua like
me I will say that she does not look
like you bro really yeah you don't have
a look at stuff if you were born raised
in Florida this antony's yeah they got
him son for a hot second yeah
yeah she's so sunburned she has pugs
coming out of her shirt she definitely
I'm confused so is that a pillow or is
that one giant shirt with two dogs
well he'll tell us if he says something
Derek we don't know about if it's a
pillow or not looks like a pillow to me
but I'm not a hundred percent sure man I
know what's going on there and she
didn't have a pug only thing we know
about her is she lives in the desert and
we know that dog needs to get it
sticking up her face
Jesus Christ men yes look at the dog is
your real respect bro she's a famous
woman ever seen in my life
that dog looks like it [ __ ] pays for
everybody's tab at Benihana and he has a
[ __ ] vest on who is he he's off see
educated we know that fast on he's
[ __ ] Pippin this old lady out he's
pretty dope is he a detective dude look
his dog is a [ __ ] is he an action from
the movie seven with Morgan Freeman but
he's a few guns on each side forty-eight
strapped around his neck do we zoom in
on this pop a little he has a 48
strapped on her a 49 and he's posed his
dick out dude yeah guess I'm bad
clothing it's almost you Brendan
you didn't give a [ __ ] dusty he never
has given a [ __ ] dude if you [ __ ] if
you frisked him you would not find any
[ __ ] on him bro no [ __ ] and let's zoom
out is that definitely a bugger is that
et on that pillow looks like et did dis
imprison time is a lot going on
what's she asking about yeah well she
went to her bike in the back what's
going on have no idea where there's so
many bikes in the back but uh no she's
just wanting she's hot yeah oh she's
just saying what's up fellas I'm mad at
the tan not mad at all the pups way too
many bikes I get some question about
that whatever yeah but I'll say this you
are one of the people that doesn't
realize how tan you are and it's and it
might because you're colorblind it could
be because I wonder a lot of this people
that a lot of these people see the world
in a different colour because you can
see orange or something you're four
shades past whatever you need to be like
you definitely overcooked oh you could
easily get shot by cops for possibly
reaching for something in your car like
you're [ __ ] going dangerously dark
we're trying to help you out lighten up
just a few shades and Steel's trying to
tell you you're getting risky okay you
look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] Julius the
pugs are beautiful the [ __ ] she looks
like the biggest Oompa Loompa those
things were worn just [ __ ] yeah yeah you
look like open our dough DiCaprio you're
[ __ ] coming in edge lupa there is you
look like somebody's aunt if they're a
hot dog then all be friends
Cheska baby that all be frank if I can
hear that Betty bratwurst yeah you don't
think the last hot dog left on this
spinning thank you
at the gas station hi only wrinkly brow
just sweating already bro bro back off
the bronzer you look like a third place
trophy at this point I'm surprised
somebody just hang you around their neck
at the Olympics
you gotta tighten up a little bit but
with that I got the worst body at the
[ __ ] mr. Olympia your main Brendan
but you have to say about her body or
bodies nice Brendan no I'm talking about
color here shout out to this lady the
Malik the dogs I like her dog is a you
know he's a little promiscuous it's
whatever I like his vast I like that she
had the balls to take this picture nope
yeah ended I think there's a lot going
on in this picture and I love it in yes
and he just orange orange down a little
and uh and you're a dime you're a dime
and a half you're at least I'd say more
like a penny but yeah really well
pennies are bronze good call yeah
you win this round all right boys wrap
it up now with a little king under sting
it up first we have ty Trahan from LA
interesting and I feel like every
segment is the same I feel like flop my
own Punk my own they're the same person
the odds are so manly healthy kids are
changing time will discriminate here bro
time these these these brown is brown
dude a lot of these [ __ ] are hard out
there you know the same brother who's
this guy
this is ty from Lafayette thanks for the
clear picture yes dude it's human bro
Justin the diamond for a Lafayette
Louisiana gang gang gang buzz-buzz walk
can you distinguish whoa Wow bro you
ain't Kevin Costner this ain't dance is
weirdo loves dude you're in New Orleans
with a [ __ ] white fang he's in
Lafayette IN it's fado doe with the
Wolves baby I like and listening to some
zydeco music right there that's [ __ ]
Jack London bro that's that cocaina
[ __ ] wolf - nothing is pure
right in the oh I think you could cut
that up and if I can snort at least one
of his legs bro
at least sniff his nose damn thing is
gangster little too relaxed the wolf's
there are not dogs man those things they
got those mean streaks and them but do
you want a dog nowadays look what the
other dogs doing in that lady's picture
is sitting there erect on a couch
putting its dick yeah this thing's a
professional look at him man you think
he ones robbing that guy's house Tony
his White Fang hanging the [ __ ]
bedroom with him all the goddamn time
not a chance ever I would put a note on
your it says unless you've read up on
Jack London I wouldn't even [ __ ] step
foot in my house yeah you ain't lying
dude dude this thing right here unless
you're Kevin Costner don't come in this
[ __ ] crib you know I'm saying yeah
what's that book um hunter Wolf's or
whatever missed that one
oh no you're talking about snow dogs
dumbass no I'm not you're in seen it's a
documentary about dogs do coke run
cocaine across the border snow dogs it's
a Colombian documentary oh yeah which is
basically the same thing
sure I'm already in it that guy uh back
to this thing Lord no does not exist for
Cuba continue that Louisiana wolf I
would start mating and breeding this
thing because we need more Wolf's out
there we need wolf sir part a real part
of nature not these fake-ass dogs they
got out here here's my thing if a
frisbee will kill it it's not a dog okay
you throw a frisbee a catch in his mouth
and if [ __ ] needs to go to the
hospital [ __ ] it son
that ain't a dog it's something that we
created some [ __ ] yes a man made
Paul boo yeah that's a little twice
thinks about gangster these pit bulls
row up to the park of the [ __ ] Wharf
on y'all Maxie what's up oh [ __ ] some
people up that's what I'm saying man you
too Lord a light bra right here you
working you're working against the dark
arts it seems like a hundred percent be
a lot less crime if everyone had Wolf's
in the goddamn house praise God brother
shut
- whoops I'm gang dude [ __ ] awesome this
is from John know what it is I'm with
John [ __ ] snap turn I throw the kids and
that's for them boys putting their dicks
on and girls putting their titties on
their I don't [ __ ] with that skein Juris
too much [ __ ]
aren't you getting a bunch of [ __ ]
and death threats on there yeah yes
exactly
no junk I'm getting [ __ ] and death
threats on the head I don't need that in
my life right now I got him I got a stay
order Instagram people send me their
[ __ ] on Instagram I don't want that snap
in my face
I'm with homeboy here it's too confusing
shout to that guy yeah first of all this
guy regularly needs to send in videos
due because he's great
yeah he's chewing vegan yellow gum which
has got to be very cancerous for your
body
you think he's worried about that huh
you think he's worried about the cancer
from the gum yeah dude the guy is a
[ __ ] legend bro he's definitely
legend shoutout to John shut up - JB
those are two guys that sending some
swaggy videos Brahmas jump some gravy
just think about it the wolf the [ __ ]
houseboat okay somebody cutting corners
on a [ __ ] a house above take a
picture of somebody food part of a red
door
van so they could send it in for chide
my ride this is the only show on [ __ ]
plant on the planet that's ran by fans
through pictures videos this show man
guys it's true bro and what did it
snapchat it's very dangerous you don't
want to get into it it's a dirty hill to
go down there'd be the dark arts of
social media am i right on there yeah I
know there's some fake profiles to me
I'm not on there if you have big pics
that's not real it's not me I've been
threatened on there dude and so I try to
stay off it man every now and then if
I'm not if I'm [ __ ] reeling at night
or something I'll get on there
crack open two things and it's real real
spooky so I try to scout their space
like opening up your front door and
anybody could be out there you know
could be a bowl of soup pinned or be
Saudis [ __ ] could be somebody killing
somebody somebody sent me a thing
killing their friend what the [ __ ] is
this man and then it's on you we're like
at least put you know Tallahassee or
[ __ ] in it you know let's get chin on
the case yeah so I mean I'm not
reporting murders everywhere but I don't
have that kind of time you know I'm not
calling 3,000 police department or
should you you feel me yeah shut up to
this dude though I don't [ __ ] with snap
either brothers gang yes stay off it
dude stick to what you know bro that's
it boys that's it that's our man good to
be back in her brother love your shirt
you seem a little uh a little refreshed
after Disneyland with the fam
yeah man exactly what you needed me I
feel pretty good it was fun we had a
nice time good to see what's going on
over there I like the swag yeah thank
you it's very very nice
Polynesian huh cat nope nope nope that's
from the house of bird Mele Kalikimaka
Leakey is the place for me
we're brother let me get a burn in here
I'm in Las Vegas man Friday night this
Friday Oh Saturday night I'm in
Sacramento in Las Vegas this Thursday
Friday and Saturday and um yeah I've
bunch of dates Theo von comm / torti oh
you are good
he's one of the best in the world I'm in
Portland Portland helium this
thursday/friday cell phone I know I love
that place
Portland helium I'm bringing my boy
Derrick post in here Chappelle yeah it's
coming with me so buddy is Jerry but so
what he was a cheerleader bro he showed
me a comic book he had the other day
yeah bro Brown it up a little too white
for me hot topic mate for you bro yeah
I'm in [ __ ] Portland with Tim and
then after that I got shown the ice out
September Houston Denver tickets I
didn't get awesome man and yep we'll see
you guys in the future thank you guys
for supporting this podcast tank gang
buzz-buzz
[Music]
the king nice name
[Music]